Lebanon welcome
Oh
Wow
rock stars
George George just their darkside rock
stars but because of your reception
thank you what a wonderfully sinister
reunion we have here fantastic to vote
you out what it's really good to see you
guys
in George created for you some
deliciously evil scenes do you have a
favorite of all the deliciously evil
scenes and there are many like I can't
think there is one theme that isn't
deliciously evil the one that stands out
for me is in Revenge of the Sith and
that when we all get to go to the Opera
George George will remember that he
wrote that scene originally in another
office and I kept getting bigger and
bigger offices all the time as I got
more and more powerful because you know
that what happens and then he said no I
think we should go somewhere else for a
change so we went to a theater and the
reason I like doing that so much because
I'm a theatre actor too but more than
that Hagen and I could really sit down
and from my point of view anyway have an
evil chat and I think George you correct
me if I'm wrong I think it's one of the
longest dialogue scenes in the whole of
the saga and I was allowed to tell a
story you know and really really connect
so that was exciting two fabulous
fabulous
tell us why it was like working with Ian
a hugely experienced actor were you
intimidated at all
Oh working with with Ian was was just a
real treatment privilege I mean everyone
knows that he's such an amazing actor
but he's also an incredibly generous
actor and and really kind of took me
under his wing and and and was just very
caring and giving and and I owe a lot of
what I was able to accomplish in Episode
three to being able to work within him
you know that seem that he's talking
about was one of my favorites and I just
I remember just being so interacted with
with the story that he was telling that
I almost forgot that I was acting in the
scene I was like oh no I got it do my
part now too but it was just it was you
know he's so captivating in his work and
it was it was amazing
well it's a truism that l direct has
learned from younger access to and
working with him was a great learning
experience I would say the one testament
to IANS acting and how great he is is
he's the nicest loveliest kindest
sweetest guy in the world he is nothing
at all like the Emperor well maybe
occasionally not only did you deliver a
brilliant acting performance but also
your lightsaber battle at the end of
Revenge of the Sith what
tell us a little bit about your
punctuating for that final battle yeah
sure of course I I mean all the
lightsaber work was some of my you know
favorite parts of getting to play this
character and be a part of the Star Wars
world you know it was just a childhood
dream come true but I will share with
you one of my challenges you know I had
sort of been conditioned from a very
young age to make the sound effect when
I'm like and you know I know this was
something that you and maybe struggled
with a little bit too but it was it was
a difficult habit to break and I
remember on a couple of occasions George
you you would come over after we had
filmed the a fight scene and you know in
a very encouraging way you would say
Hayden oh that looks really great but I
can see your mouth moving and you know
you don't have to do that we had to
sound effects and afterwards and and I
you know I was just so focused I wasn't
even aware I was doing it but you know
still to this day I pick up a lightsaber
and I just I can't help it
these guys these guys you and union
Hayden were so brilliant at it and they
practiced every morning I usually
casually see them when I popped into
practice a little but the external thing
about was every time we did the cake
there must've been about 20 probably
more they did the whole sequence which
was absolutely extraordinary man you see
it in the movie is terrific but it
necessary edited and split up and I used
to say they should take their tables
both of them and get on the road to show
how brilliant fighters they really were
Bela forgot your first meeting the
Georgian how he described this character
to you oh yeah well he didn't jump
George doesn't go in for lengthy
explanations which is great we met very
briefly over lunch time with Richard
Marquand it is of course Return of the
Jedi and I was very pleased to meet them
both thrills of course and then we set
up a like goodbyes and I went back home
and the phone was ringing my agent said
you've got the part that's great
what's the part and he went in our
agents do leafing through piles of you
know papers and they said Oh apparently
he's called the Emperor of the universe
so I said oh well I guess were doing it
then and and from then on it was makeup
hood yellow eyes and under under script
and I think most of my information and
most actors would agree about have came
from the script although George was
always around them very helpful but
because he wasn't specifically directing
that movie that was that was Richard and
of course I got to go on doing it and
what we met again before the prequels
George was there wearing very similar
shirt too
so the one he's wearing today and and he
said oh can we get you a drink
I thought I'll just sell no no it's just
you know copy it coffee water and I
thought I'll have the water and then he
said you know anybody who wants to play
an emperor so I said yeah yeah that's me
and that was the audition for for that
for the prequel and then he said there
are two characters the character you
play in this is Palpatine of course and
he's a hypocritical politician you know
we've all got to start somewhere and but
there's this other character and you
didn't tell me the name you know this in
the background he does this and he does
that I thought I'd really like to play
that other character and then I got the
scripts and I realized I was playing
both of them and so do you eventually
apparently George isn't there a story
you were particularly taken with Ian's
nose though oh well I look at his
profile now it's quite I think you deny
this when we when we left that very
short and agreeable meeting in the
doorway you say hey great knows that and
I thought well maybe that means I'm
going to get some work are you sure I
don't remember doing yeah
yes fantastic well thank you both for
being so brilliant here today
six-zero your function even to scholars
ladies and gentlemen in medomak and
Hayden Christensen me Nikki me Mickey
[Music]